AND HELLO AGAIN FROM FOX NEWS IN
WASHINGTON.
WE SAW MAJOR ACTION BY THE FDA
AND CDC THIS WEEK TO APPROVE
BOOSTER SHOTS FOR MILLIONS MORE
AMERICANS.
AND ALSO, NEW GUIDANCE ON MIX
AND MATCH TO GETTING THE INITIAL
DOSE OF ONE VACCINE AND THEN A
BOOSTER SHOT OF ANOTHER.
PLUS, PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES ARE
GETTING CLOSER TO APPROVING
CODED VACCINES FOR CHILDREN
UNDER 12.
AND OF THE CONTROVERSY CONTINUES
OVER PUBLIC AGENCIES AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES IMPOSING VACCINE
MANDATES ON THEIR EMPLOYEES.
ALL THIS AS AMERICANS TRY TO
PREPARE FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THERE'S PLENTY
TO DISCUSS WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL,
DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY.
DOCTOR, WELCOME BACK TO "FOX
NEWS SUNDAY."
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK,
GOOD MORNING, CHRIS.
>> Chris: IT'S THIS WEEK THE
CDC APPROVED THE MODERNITY AND
AT J&J VACCINES FOR MILLIONS
MORE AMERICANS AS WELL AS
APPROVING MIX AND MATCH.
YOU SAY THAT IT'S A PERSONAL
OPTION AS TO THE INDIVIDUAL,
WHETHER THEY WANT TO GET THE
INITIAL DOSE OF ONE VACCINE AND
THEN THE BOOSTER OF ANOTHER
VACCINE.
BUT ISN'T THE DATA CLEAR THAT IF
YOU GOT THE J&J BOOSTER FIRST,
YOU GET MUCH MORE PROD PROTECTIY
GETTING A BOOSTER FROM EITHER
PFIZER OR AN MODE OR NOT?
>> Dr. Walensky: THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT NEXT STEP IN OUR
BOOSTER PLAN ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
BLISTER PLAN FOR EVERY ONE OF
THE VACCINES THAT WE ARE USING.
AS YOU NOTED, THE MODERNA WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR BOOSTING AS
WELL AS THE J&J TWO MONTHS AFTER
THE INITIAL DOSE.
WE ALSO DEVELOPED A PLAN WHERE
WE CAN WORK FORWARD FOR MIX AND
MATCH BUT SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
QUESTION, THE FDA AND CDC SAW
IMPORTANT DATE OF FROM THE NIH
ON THE MIX-AND-MATCH APPROACH.
AND HOW WHEN YOU BOOST A J&J
VACCINE IT WITH A PFIZER OR
MODERNA VACCINE, YOU GET A
REALLY GOOD ANTIBODY RESPONSE.
WE ALSO SAW CLINICAL DATA FROM
J&J THEMSELVES THAT WHEN YOU
BOOST THE J&J WITH THE J&J
VACCINE, YOU GET REALLY GOOD
EFFEEFFECTIVENESS THERE AS WELL.
THAT'S WHY WE LEFT IT TO THE
PEOPLE BECAUSE QUITE HONESTLY,
MOST PEOPLE DID REALLY WELL WITH
THEIR INITIAL VACCINE SERIES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE DID
REALLY WELL AND WE HAVE
410 MILLION PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED, OR FOR 10 MILLION
VACCINES THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
AND SO PEOPLE WANT TO PICK THE
ONE THAT THEY GOT BEFORE BUT IF
YOU WANT SOMETHING ELSE, WE LEFT
THAT OPTION UP TO YOU.
>> Chris: IT JUST BRIEFLY
THOUGH, ACCORDING TO THE DATA,
IF YOU GET THE J&J BOOSTER AFTER
YOU GET THE INITIAL DOSE, IT
BOOSTED YOUR ANTIBODIES
FOURFOLD.
IF YOU GOT THE MODERNA AFTER THE
J&J AT BOOSTER ANTIBODIES 76
FOLD.
IF YOU ARE TALKING TO A FRIEND
OR RELATIVE, IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
A NO BRAIN ARE.
>> Chri>> Dr. Walensky: WE'S HAE
DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF DATA BUT WE
SAW PEOPLE AND CLINICAL
EFFECTIVENESS THAT DEMONSTRATED
A REALLY GOOD RESPONSE TO J&J AS
WELL.
SO I WOULD LEAVE IT UP TO THE
CLINICAL SITUATION IF I WAS
TALKING TO A SPECIFIC PERSON.
IF PEOPLE WANT J&J AGAIN, THEN
THEY MIGHT VERY WELL WANT AN
MRNA ON THAT WOULD BE FINE,
TOO.
>> Chris: COULD YOU AT SOME
POINT CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT IT NEEDS TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED TO THE COMIC INITIAL
DOSE, PLUS THE BOOSTER, IF
THAT'S GOING TO BE WHAT IT ME
MEANS?
>> Dr. Walensky: THE
DEFINITION OF FULLY VACCINATED
IS PFIZER OR MATURING AFTER YOU
HAVE RECEIVED TWO DOSES, YOU ARE
CONSIDERED FULLY VACCINATED.
AND AFTER J&J, A SINGLE DOSE,
YOU ARE CONSIDERED FULLY
VACCINATED.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
>> Chris: THE BOOSTERS WILL
NOT CHANGE THAT DEFINITION, AT
LEAST AT THIS POINT?
AND >> Dr. Walensky: WE DON'T
HAVE A PLAN TO CHANGE THAT
DEFINITION RIGHT NOW.
>> Chris: THE FDA A PANEL OF
BOTH THIS WEEK ON WHETHER TO
APPROVE THE EMERGENCY USE OF THE
PFIZER VACCINE FOR 28 MILLION
CHILDREN AGES FIVE THROUGH 11,
AND A CDC PANEL WAS SUPPOSED TO
MEET THE WEEK AFTER NEXT, THE
FIRST WEEK OF NOVEMBER.
ASSUMING ALL GOES WELL, HOW SOON
COULD YOU BE SITTING THERE AS A
CDC DIRECTOR SAYING THE KIDS
FIVE THROUGH 11, IT'S SAFE TO
GET A VACCINE?
>> Dr. Walensky: WE KNOW HOW
MANY PARENTS ARE INTERESTED IN
GETTING THEIR CHILDREN
VACCINATED AND WE INTEND TO WORK
AS QUICKLY AS YOU CAN.
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THE FDA
WILL MEET THIS WEEK AND SOON
THEREAFTER, AS THEY ARE ABLE TO
REVIEW ALL THE SCIENCE AND
CONDUCT REGULATORY ACTION, THE
CDC WILL MEET.
AND IF ALL OF THAT GOES
SMOOTHLY, AFTER REVIEWING ALL
THAT SCIENCE AND DOING THE
PROPER SCIENTIFIC DUE DILIGENCE,
WE WILACT QUICKLY.
WHAT I CAN ALSO SAY IS, IN THE
MEANTIME HERE IS IMPORTANT TO
LOGISTICAL AND OPERATIONAL PLANS
THAT ARE UNDERWAY SO THAT THAT
VACCINE WILL BE OUT IN THE FIELD
AS SOON AS WE TAKE ACTION.
>> Chris: LOOK, IT'S ONE THING
TO SAY WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO
GET A VACCINE.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO SAY
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WILL GET YOUR
5-YEAR-OLD A VACCINE.
IN A POLL THAT JUST CAME OUT
ONLY ONE-THIRD OF PARENTS SAID
THEY WOULD BE WILLING TO LET
THEIR CHILDREN, EVEN IF IT'S
APPROVED BY THE FDA AND CDC, LET
SMALL CHILDREN GET THE VACCINE
"RIGHT AWAY."
DO YOU THINK -- HOW TOUGH DO YOU
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE TO
CONVINCE PARENTS AFTER YOU GO
THROUGH THESE APPROVALS THAT
IT'S SAFE TO GIVE A
5-11-YEAR-OLD KID A VACCINE
ANTE, AT THAT POINT SHOULD
SCHOOLS MANDATE THAT KIDS OF THE
SAGE GET THE VACCINE AS THEY DO
LOTS OF OTHER VACCINES?
>> Dr. Walensky: RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE -- I'M REALLY EXCITED
AND ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT REVIEWING
THE SCIENCE AND I'M REALLY
HOPEFUL THAT IN THAT PROPER
REVIEW WILL WE'LL GET TO A POINT
WHERE WE HAVE A VACCINE FOR
5-11-YEAR-OLDS.
WHEN AND IF WE DO, WE HAVE A LOT
OF PARENTS, AS YOU NOTED, A
THIRD WHO ARE READY TO GET THEIR
VACCINATED RIGHT AWAY, AND WE
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK OUT
OF US JUST AS WE DID WITH THE
INITIAL VACCINE.
THESE NUMBERS ARE THE SAME AS
THEY WERE EARLY DECEMBER LAST
YEAR WHEN THE INITIAL VACCINE
ROLLED OUT AND AS OF TODAY WE
HAVE 80% OF PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
THEIR FIRST DOSE.
WE HAVE TO DO ALL OF THAT HARD
WORK AGAIN.
EDUCATION, COMMUNICATION, SO WE
CAN GET PARENTS COMFORTABLE WITH
GETTING THEIR CHILDREN
VACCINATED WHERE SO MANY PARENTS
ARE ALREADY.
>> Chris: HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
ABOUT SCHOOLS MANDATING THOSE
VACCINES ONCE THEY ARE FULLY
APPROVED?
>> Dr. Walensky: RIGHT NOW WE
ARE AT AUTHORIZATION, WE ARE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
AUTHORIZATION SO I THINK WE NEED
TO GET CHILDREN VACCINATED
THROUGH THIS AUTHORIZATION AND
TO GET TO APPROVAL BEFORE WE CAN
MAKE A JUDGMENT THERE.
>> Chris: LET'S TALK ABOUT
MANDATES FOR ADULTS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE QUITE CONTROVERSIAL MAATES
FOR ESSENTL WORKERS AT HIS
TOWN HALL THIS WEEK.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS ANSWER.
>> SHOULD POLICE OFFICERS,
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS BE MANDATED
TO GET VACCINES, AND IF NOT,
SHOULD THEY BE STAY AT HOME OR
THAT GO?
>> President Biden: YES AND
YES.
>> Chris: IT NOW IF MANDATES
BY GOVERNMENT AND BY PRIVATE
COMPANIES H OF ESSENTIAL WORKER,
GENERALLY THERE'S A BIG BOOST OF
VACCINATIONS EVEN THOUGH THERE
MAY BE SOME GROUSING, BUT THERE
ARE CASES OF POLICE OFFICERS OR
HEALTH WORKERS OR PILOTS THAT
ARE WALKING UP THE JOB RATHER
THAN GET THE VACCINE.
ARE YOU STILL FULL SPEED AHEAD
ON MANDATES FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO GET VACCINATED?
>> Dr. Walensky: WE HAVE SEEN
THAT THESE MANDATES ARE GETTING
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
THE MOST DISRUPTIVE THING THAT
YOU CAN DO TO A WORKFORCE IS TO
HAVE A COVERT OUTBREAK AND NOT
WORKFORCE.
THAT WAS DEFINITELY NOT LY
SEND PEOPLE HOME BUT SEND PEOPLE
TO THE HOSPITAL AND SOME MAY
PASS.
WHAT WE KNOW FROM THE POLICE
WORKFORCE IS THERE HAVE BEEN
MORE DEATHS FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
THAN ALL OTHER CAUSES OF DEATH
FOR THAT WORKFORCE COMBINED.
SO WE BELIEVE IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO GET THESE PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
THERE IS A PLAN, SHOULD THESE
PEOPLE NOT WANT TO BE
VACCINATED, TOWARDS EDUCATION
AND COUNSELING TO GET PEOPLE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED SO THAT
THEY ARE FEELING COMFORTABLE IN
GETTING VACCINATED.
>> Chris: BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
ARGUMENT, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH HERE.
AND IF YOU GET -- AND WE'D SEEN
SOME REAL RESISTANCE FOR
INSTANCE IN THE CHICAGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT, AND INTEREST OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ON VACCINATIONS,
IF YOU HAVE A LARGE PART OF THE
POLICE FORCE LEAVING, IN TERMS
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AREN'T YOU
FURTHER BEHIND THE BALL RATHER
THAN HAVING MADE GAINS?
>> Dr. Walensky: YOU KNOW, THE
WAY YOU CAN DOWN A POLICE FORCE
IS BY AN OUTBREAK IN THAT POLICE
FORCE SO WHAT WE ARE WORKING TO
DO IS MITIGATE TT FROM
HAPPENING.
>> Chris: FINALLY, LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON COVID.
LET ME PUT SOME OF THE LATEST
STOCKS UP.
CASES ARE DOWN, MORE THAN 50% IN
THE LAST MONTH.
BUT WE ARE STILL SEEING AN
AVERAGE OF MORE THAN 73,000 NEW
CASES PER DAY AND MORE THAN 1500
DEATHS PER DAY WHICH IS STILL
PRETTY BAD.
SO FIRST OF ALL, WHERE ARE WE ON
THE DELTA WAVE?
>> Dr. Walensky: I THINK THE
NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU ARE ABSENTLY RIGHT, CASES
ARE DOWN COME UP WITH THAN 50%
FROM WHERE THEY WERE IN
SEPTEMBER BUT WE CAN'T GET
COMPLACENT YET.
AS WE SAID TO COME AT 75,000
CASES PER DAY AND 1500 DEATHS
PER DAY.
THE GOOD NEWS COMPARED TO WHERE
WE WERE A YEAR AGO IS THAT WE
HAVE VACCINES AT WORK AND THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF SCIENCE THAT
DEMONSTRATES HOW WE CAN PROTECT
OURSELVES AND HOW WE CAN GET
CASES DOWN FURTHER.
WE KNOW IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED, ALTHOUGH4 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT YET BEEN
VACCINATED, AND THEN WITH
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW, IF WE HAVE A
VACCINE FOR OUR 5-11-YEAR-OLDS
WORKING TO GET THEM VACCINATED
AND IN THE MEANTIME PRACTICING
THE PROPER MITIGATION STRATEGIES
SO WE CAN GET THE CASE NUMBERS
AND DEATH NUMBERS DOWN.
>> Chris: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE IN THE DOWNTURN OF THE
DELTA WAVE, THAT THE SPIKE IS
OVER AND IT'S HEADING OUT?
>> Dr. Walensky: YOU KNOW, I'M
REALLY ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
NUMBERS GO DOWN.
THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS, THEY HAVE
BEEN HANGING OUT AT AROUND
75,000 AND SO WE STILL HAVE SOME
HARD WORK AHEAD OF US IN ORDER
TO BRING THOSE NUMBERS DOWN TO
WHERE THEY WERE IN MAY AND JUNE.
>> Chris: AND YOU HEAR PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THIS, BUT WHAT ARE
THE CHANCES OF ANOTHER FIFTH
WAVE OF THE VIRUS AS IT BEGINS
TO GET COLDER AND PEOPLE START
SPENDING MORE TIME INDOORS?
>> Dr. Walensky: WELL, I'M
ENCOURAGED BY NUMBERS COMING
DOWN RIGHT NOW BUT I HAVE
LEARNED THAT WE CAT BE
COMPLACENT AND THAT WE NEED TO
BE HUMBLE.
THE VIRUS TENDS TO FIND PLACES
THAT ARE UNDER VACCINATED.
AS OUR CASE NUMBERS COME DOWN WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO THE HARD
WORK OF GETTING MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE VACCINATED TO PREVENT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU DESCRIBED.
>> Chris: THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD SPORTS ON TV THESE DAYS AND
IF YOU WATCH SPORTS, WHETHER
IT'S FOOTBALL GAMES AND STADIUMS
OR PLAYOFFS IN BASEBALL, WE GOT
SOME PICTURES UP ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW, DOCTOR.
YOU SEE HUNDREDS, THOUSANDS,
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ALL
PACKED TOGETHER.
NOT A MASK INSIGHT.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S OUTDOORS, BUT
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU, THAT
THERE HAVE NOT BEEN SPIKES IN
MOST OF THESE COMMUNITIES WHEN
YOU HAVE PEOPLE CROWDED INTO
FOOTBALL OR BASEBALL STADIUMS?
>> Dr. Walensky: WE WOULD
STILL ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON VACCINATED TO WEAR A MASK IN
THOSE SITUATIONS, BUT GIVEN THAT
THESE GAMES ARE OUTDOORS, THAT
TENDS TO BE A MUCH SAFER
ENVIRONMENT.
>> Chris: FINALLY, THE
HOLIDAYS.
FIRST OF ALL, HALLOWEEN.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO  TO OF THE
KIDS CAN DO AND CAN'T DO.
>> Dr. Walensky: I WOULD SAY
PUT ON THOSE COSTUMES, STAY
OUTSIDE AND ENJOY YOUR TRICK OR
TREATING.
>> Chris: WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
VACCINATED OR NOT, AS LONG AS
YOU'RE OUTSIDE, YOU ARE SAFE?
>> Dr. Walensky: I WOULDN'T
GATHER IN LARGE SETTINGS OUTSIDE
AND DO SCREAMING LIKE YOU ARE
SEEING IN THOSE FOOTBALL GAMES,
IF YOU ARE UNVACCINATED, BUT IF
YOU ARE SPREAD OUT DOING YOUR
DOING OR TRICK-OR-TREATING, THAT
SHOULD BE VERY SAFE FOR YOUR
CHILDREN.
>> Chris: WHAT ABOUT
THANKSGIVING AND CHRISTMAS?
>> Dr. Walensky: YOU KNOW,
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE GATHER AND BE WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS DURING THE HOLIDAYS AND
WE HAVE THE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES THAT WE KNOW WORK TO
BE SAFE FOR THOSE HOLIDAYS.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS GET
YOURSELF VACCINATED BEFORE YOU
GATHER, IT WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
SAFER IF YOU'RE VACCINATED.
ANY ACTIVITY THAT IS OUTDOORS A
SAFER THAN IT IS IF IT'S
INDOORS.
AND IF YOU ARE GATHERING
MULTIPLE HOUSEHOLDS, MAKE SURE
AS MANY PEOPLE ARE VACNATED AS
POSSIBLE SO YOU CAN PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE VULNERABLE, WHO
MIGHT NOT YET BE VACCINATED.
OUR YOUNG CHILDREN AND OUR
ELDERLY.
AND DO ALL THOSE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES THAT WE KNOW WORK
BEFORE YOU ARRIVE AND AS YOU
ARRIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN BE SAFE FOR THE
HOLIDAYS AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE WELL AS YOU GATHER.
>> Chris: DR